pas présent accueillir notre grand
témoin les femmes rabbins écrivains et
bien plus encore en témoigne son dernier
livre un texte court très drôle mordant
contre tous les obsédés de l'identité il
n'y a pas de Hajar chez Grasset
monologue ou elle l'imagine un fils à
Émilie la jarre le fils d'une
falsification littéraire celle de
l'écrivain Romain Gary s'est vertigineux
Delphine orvillers nous rejoint tout de
suite après l'invitation de Clément
Méric avec ce soir Charlotte c'est bien
à l'image
si on vous invite Delphine orvillers
c'est pour nous aider à répondre à une
question pas si simple qui suis-je tenez
vous-même qui êtes-vous Delphine
anwiller si on se penche sur votre CV la
réponse la plus immédiate est femme
rabbin sauf que vous avez aussi été
mannequin et journaliste après le bac
vous partez en Israël c'est là que vous
faites du mannequinat pour financer vos
études de médecine vos bifurkez ensuite
vers le journalisme et devenez reporter
à France Télé le projet de loi présenté
aujourd'hui par le ministre de la Santé
Bernard Kouchner va dans le sens de ce
mecs mais en 2003 nouveau virage vous
quittez la France pour vous inscrire
dans une école rabbinique à New York 5
ans plus tard vous devenez la troisième
femme rabbin à exercer en France de ce
cheminement vous tirez une leçon on n'a
jamais fini de dire ce qu'on pourrait
être c'est à dire que il existe dans la
vie toujours une possibilité de devenir
autre chose et que il y a rien de pire
que de s'imaginer qu'on est arrivé
il n'y a donc pas une mais plusieurs
Delphine orvillers ne pas se laisser
renfermer dans une seule identité c'est
justement le thème de votre dernier
livre il n'y a pas de Hajar texte joué
actuellement au Théâtre des plateaux
sauvages dans ce monologue vous prêtez
votre plume au fils imaginaire des
milles ajars pseudo de Romain Gary qui
fut lui-même écrivain mais aussi
aviateur diplomate et réalisateur il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'on est
ce que nos naissances ont fait de nous
nos ethnies nos religions nos parents
nos filiation mais moi je voilà je
suggère dans ce texte que on n'est pas
juste les enfants de nos parents ou de
nos familles on est bien souvent en tout
cas moi je me reconnais là dedans on est
les enfants des livres qu'on a lu et ça
m'a rejeté disait que de façon très
juste que la simplification de nos
identités nous amène à voir très vite en
l'autre un ennemi au fil des pages de ce
livre si différents des autres une
question nous vient Delphine nordviller
à l'image de Romain Gary ne seriez-vous
pas une fois de plus en train de vous
réinventer
[Musique]
bonsoir Delphine nordviller bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être là alors il n'y a
pas de Hajar monologue contre l'identité
chez Grasset c'est une autre Delphine
orchiller qu'on découvre qu'on rencontre
un peu différente je dirais très très
drôle mordant parfois même un Solente
est-ce que c'est aussi ça ce livre
est-ce qu'à l'image de Romain Gary de
son œuvre et de toute sa vie vous aviez
envie de vous réinventer oui c'est vrai
que je j'aime l'idée qu'on n'a jamais
fini de dire qui on est je me rends
compte dans le sujet que vous avez
présenté que je je le dis depuis un
moment mais ce livre me permet de le
dire un peu plus fortement de faire un
pas de côté et puis c'était important
pour moi de l'écrire après vivre avec
nos morts qui était mon livre précédent
qui était sur un sujet très lourd pesant
le deuil qui menaçait un peu pour moi de
m'enfermer dans un certain rôle rabbini
d'accompagnement des familles
endeuillées et j'avais besoin de
reprendre un peu d'oxygène d'écrire un
peu autrement d'avoir recours aussi à la
fiction à l'exagération parce que le
personnage de ce livre est un peu moins
mais quand même pas complètement
heureusement il est beaucoup plus
exubérant et énervé et en colère que je
ne beaucoup plus que je ne le suis alors
c'est Abraham Hajar on va en parler
longuement qui est interprété par Joanna
lisard donc une femme une comédienne
c'est sur la scène du Théâtre des
plateaux sauvages alors jusqu'au 7
octobre et ce sera ensuite au Théâtre du
Rond-Point c'est bien ça ça va à
Villejuif à Suresnes dans bien des
théâtres et ce sera au Théâtre du
Rond-Point en décembre avant de
commencer une tournée alors quelle
histoire quelle histoire de cette fille
vous traite Romain Gary la plus grande
supercherie littéraire écrivez-vous du
20e siècle Gary le seul écrivain avoir
reçu deux prix Goncourt l'un pour les
Racines du ciel sous son nom romain Gary
l'autre pour la vie devant soi sous son
pseudonyme et Émile Ajar d'abord
racontez-nous ce lien intime et
invisible que vous avez avec lui depuis
l'enfance quasiment depuis votre
naissance oui je dis souvent que Gary
est pour moi comme un ebooks moi en
hébreu qui signifie comme un fant ou
quelqu'un qui vous hante j'ai
l'impression que ces livres m'ont
accompagné je me vois encore adolescente
lire la promesse de l'aube voilà étant
d'autres livres la vie devant soi la
jarre tous ces livres qui m'ont
construit d'une certaine manière et
c'est vrai que je me suis sentie
toujours lié d'une certaine manière à la
tentative de Gary Gary c'est vraiment
quelqu'un par excellence qui a voulu se
réinventer et dire qu'il avait jamais
fini de dire qu'il était il s'est
construit 1000 vies j'ai souvent le
sentiment que Gary incarne pour moi la
figure du survivant dans tous les sens
du terme il a survécu à deux guerres
mondiales et la survécu à la Shoah qui a
décimé sa famille il a survécu au combat
d'aviateur de la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais il s'est aussi installé
comme un survivant en deux mots c'est à
dire qu'il a voulu au dessus de la vie
sur et puis il a tenté toute sa vie
d'avoir une vie plus grande que la vie
c'est à dire de se dire qu'il pourrait
avoir 1000 vies à l'intérieur d'une
existence et je trouve qu'il y a pas de
plus beau défi que ça c'est pas facile à
faire c'est une étrange promesse un peu
dangereuse d'ailleurs me semble-t-il
mais souvent je me suis sentie en tout
cas un peu
héritière de ça aussi parce que j'ai
moi-même dans mon histoire dans
l'histoire de ma famille des histoires
de survivance de survie et que je me
suis souvent demandé en changeant de
chemin en changeant de route en
changeant de carrière en changeant de
pays de quelle manière il m'était donné
de recommencer cette scène que vous
racontez c'est dans la préface c'est pas
dans le monologue ou ce jour de du 2
décembre 1980 Gary mais fait un séjour
cette scène vous toquait à sa porte bon
lui raconter un conte telle musique
est-ce que vous vous l'avez vraiment
imaginé souvent personnellement c'est un
peu dans la préface bien sûr il y a la
presque un fantasme un peu de toute
puissance parce que d'imaginer que
j'aurais pu intervenir en 1980 un deux
décembre moi j'avais j'étais toute
petite toute petite à l'époque mais
c'est vrai que parfois je me suis
demandé qu'est-ce qui aurait pu se
passer si on s'était rencontrés est-ce
que ça voilà peut-être changé ce moment
déterminant en fait bien entendu c'est
la question n'est pas de savoir pourquoi
Gary s'est suicidé et si on aurait pu
interrompre suicide mais en tout cas
j'imagine une conversation que
finalement j'ai avec lui d'une certaine
manière de façon posthume les gens qui
ont compté pour vous que ce soit des
modèles des écrivains des livres des
hommes politiques parfois des sources
d'inspiration les héros de nos vies leur
particularité c'est que ils ont une
conversation avec vous parfois même
lorsqu'ils ne sont plus là quelque chose
qui peut se poursuivre dans le dialogue
que vous pourrez avoir avec eux donc
nous sommes autant que nos origines nos
familles nos héritages nous sommes aussi
les enfants des livres que nous avons vu
voilà le personnage dans le livre dit
qu'on est tous des créatures
littéralement d'une procréation
littéralement assistée en fait c'est
vrai moi je crois en tout cas moi je
perçois très bien dans ma vie comment
les livres m'ont construit ce que je
leur dois ce que je dois ma bibliothèque
à celle de mes parents mes
grands-parents aux histoires qu'on nous
a raconté alors je suis le fils je suis
le fils de la falsification légendaire
je suis l'enfant de l'entourloupe
littéraire majeur du XXe siècle je suis
le fils d'Émile à jar c'est mon père
comment ça vous est venu cette idée
franchement c'est génial d'inventer un
fils fictif à un personnage qui n'a pas
existé mais la jarre oui c'est une façon
de dire que cet enfant-là tout
particulièrement et l'enfant d'une
fiction comme on les finalement tous et
c'est aussi une façon de faire un pied
de nez pour moi à toutes ces obsessions
identitaires du moment tous ces gens qui
sont persuadés d'être qui sont parce
qu'ils sont nés quelque part qui sont
ils ont une identité bien installée
sédentarisée bien réel voilà inscrit
dans le réel moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être plus que jamais on a besoin de
réhabiliter la fiction qui agrandit la
réalité qui nous permet d'avoir encore
une fois j'avais fini de dire qui on est
c'est-à-dire de refuser des assignations
identitaires qui une fois pour vous
enferme quelque part finalement depuis
des années on n'arrête pas d'être
entouré de ces discours qui reste dans
tellement fort l'idée d'ailleurs assez
fictive qu'il existerait une pureté des
origines pourquoi vous l'avez appelé
Abraham j'ai appelé Abraham parce que
c'est là encore un peu un clin d'oeil à
l'humour d'une histoire finalement assez
méconnue Abraham c'est le père de tous
les croyants en tout cas dans les trois
monothéistes on s'est choisis dans les
trois monothéistes pour figure
paternelle un homme Abraham qui a envoyé
bouler le sien je sais pas si tout le
monde connaît cette histoire biblique
mais Abraham un jour dans la Bible
reçoit un appel ou Dieu lui dit quitte
la maison de ton père et je trouve ça à
la fois fascinant et en même temps plein
d'humour cette idée que les croyants se
choisissent pour père quelqu'un qui a
quitté la maison de son et en hébreu il
faut donner le nom du père oui on en a
en hébreu en plus il y a un élément
connu
en fait littéralement l'opèrent en
hébreu s'appelle terreur mais dans
toutes les bips vous pouvez vérifier en
français le père d'Abraham s'appelle
Taris qui fait
programme un fils de taré et des fils
d'Abraham des petits-fils de taré alors
bien sûr c'est un peu un Solange que je
dis là mais c'est volontairement j'ai
voulu titiller le texte et la tradition
parce que je crois que le texte nous y
invite souvent on dit ces dernières
années qu'on peut plus rien de tout qui
a des sujets sur lesquels on peut plus
plaisanter et surtout pas les croyances
et moi dans ce livre j'ai voulu montrer
que si au contraire nos croyances elles
sont là pour être un peu questionnés
interrogés qu'il faut parfois leur faire
un peu violence justement pour qu'elle
reste suffisamment impertinente pour
être pertinente je voudrais vous montrer
cette archive Delphine nordviller de
Romain Gary sans doute vous la
connaissez déjà parce que avant
d'inventer Hajar Gary avait déjà utilisé
un pseudo Satan Bogat pour écrire les
têtes de Stéphanie il avait été
d'ailleurs vite démasqué il explique
pourquoi il étouffait dans son image
d'écrivain établi et qu'il avait besoin
de se libérer de ça célébrité écoutez
je suis beaucoup amusé j'ai essayé de me
faire passer sous un pseudony parce que
très franchement je crois que c'est le
cas de tout le monde il y a un moment où
chacun doit servir à vie de charger de
pots de redevenir un débutant de
repartir dans une nouvelle direction et
de retrouver une certaine virginité
la connaissais cet archi et j'adore
aussi le fait que quand Gary écrivait
sous le nom d'agent il y a beaucoup de
critiques qui disait Hajar ça c'est un
grand écrivain c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux que ce Garry un peu médiocre et je
pense qu'il y a un fantasme pour tous
les écrivains d'une certaine manière
ceux qui ont de l'humour en tout cas
t'imaginer qu'on puisse écrire un livre
sous un pseudo et que quelqu'un dise
c'est quand même vachement mieux que cet
autre là toi on imagine il n'y a pas de
hasard non plus ou de Hajar Gary écrit
en hébreu signifie mon étranger ou
l'étranger en moi oui alors je sais pas
s'il le savait s'il y avait pensé je
pense pas parce que c'est pour d'autres
raisons à mon avis qu'il avait choisi ce
nom de de Gary qui a quelque chose à
voir avec le feu et la braise en russe
je crois mais en hébreu c'est vrai que
le nom de Gary signifie l'étrangeté en
moi l'étranger en moi ou mon étranger ce
qui lui va bien en fait de la même
manière que Hajar le nom qu'il se
choisit est très très proche d'un mot en
hébreu ara qui veut dire l'autre
l'altérité il s'est amusant que tous les
pseudos que se choisit en hébreu sans
doute par hasard Gary ont quelque chose
à voir avec une conscience d'altérité
avec le fait qu'il y a en nous de
l'étranger et de l'étranger qui nous
permet de jamais être complètement
authentiquement intégralement nous-même
alors c'est un livre très sincère très
tendre extrêmement drôle aussi mais
c'est aussi un livre politique comment
on fait très concrètement dans la vie de
tous les jours pour accueillir ces
identités multiples alors de ces
obsessions identitaires alors où les
jeunes générations se déchirent avec
leurs aînés à leur ont on est renvoyé
systématiquement qu'elle soit tout
défendamentalisme qui nous ramènent à
nos héritages à nos familles à nos
communautés moi je crois qu'il s'agit
toujours de complexifier le débat et de
refuser tout ce qui est monolithique
dans nos existences je relisais
récemment un livre qui moi m'a beaucoup
marqué un livre qui n'est pas de Gary
mais de Amos Oz qui a écrit un livre
magnifique qui s'appelle comment guérir
un fanatique et ce livre je pense que
tout le monde devrait lire aujourd'hui
parce qu'on est entouré de beaucoup de
fanatisme qui sont pas toujours des
fanatismes religieux d'ailleurs mais des
fanatisent de tout ordre et un mousse os
dit que le propre des fanatique c'est
que ce sont des gens qui ne savent
compter que jusque 1 et je trouve qu'il
y a rien de pire dans l'existence que
nous comptait que jusqu'à 1 c'est-à-dire
de croire qu'il y a une vérité un livre
une interprétation une façon de voir le
monde une façon de se définir
aujourd'hui on a besoin plus que jamais
de milfeuille de complexité de se
raconter comme étant ceci trois petits
points cela etc et ce combat il n'est
pas perdu d'avance
on peut le gagner à condition vous avez
le vous parler il y a un instant des
conflits intergénérationnels pour
résoudre un conflit acheteur
générationnel il faut pas nier qu'on
critique parfois des générations passées
mais il faut être capable de reconnaître
la dette c'est-à-dire de savoir tout ce
qu'on doit au monde de sa naissance
qu'on peut critiquer mais ce qu'on lui
doit également voilà
hériter transmettre autre chose par
forcément de ce qu'on a reçu merci
infiniment